what are you using to make these
miniatures or you are they're already
pre-made and you're just putting them
into place yeah yeah I I want to show
you something yeah oh wow
oh look at this yes thank you okay
this is my first drawing this is my
first drawing and you do this yeah and
then acquitting choose this one I made a
few another kind of design and oh my
gosh this is a next sketch and this is a
set this is a model
it's your mother it's interesting this
is the Quentin's drawing ha ha ha
this is my drawing hi - so just to prom
is starting point so I'm assuming
Quinton through that first and then yeah
and then I drew this one then finally
this is the final drawing print for ya
Ohan drawing this time because a Quentin
loves the analog and handmade okay yes
so no we at Department know they still
hunt and drawing